what don't people know about how family
court and divorces and separations and
stuff works for men we don't know
because we're not allowed to know our
family Court's a secret you're not
allowed to press you're not a public
there's very little oversight every time
I speak to a dad who's fighting for his
child that is the most heartbreaking
story I'll hear I'll just ask any parent
like what's the one thing you don't want
to lose and I'd say like nine times or
ten I'll see my child and when you
consider how many men are losing their
child in a system that is corrupt I feel
like that's a bigger issue than we
pretend is and not just family courts
but men are discriminated against in
many areas of Criminal Court like I know
there's been some interesting research
by Professor Sandra star and she found
that women are twice as like to avoid
prison for the same crime and if they
are sentenced men will get 63 longer
sentence that's in America but again for
the same crime same criminal history
there is a sentencing bias against black
Americans 10 is found so if you're black
in America you'll get 10 longer men get
63 longer and if you're a black man it's
63 plus 10 so you've got the compounding
of the problem itself for intersectional
approach is a really interesting and
valuable lens that we should be using